-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome,
welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
Thank you for being here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for watching.
Well, guys,
some news from Washington --
this morning, Kevin McCarthy
emerged from his hole
and saw his shadow,
which means there's
six more weeks of voting.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Yep, today at noon,
the House began their fourth day
of voting for a speaker.
I love that --
they can't get anything done,
but they still refuse to start
the workday before 12:00 p.m.
[ Laughter ]
Four straight days.
Four straight --
At this point,
the vote has lasted longer
than most people's
New Year's resolutions.
[ Laughter ]
Right now, people are betting
on which we'll get first --
the Speaker of the House
or "Avatar 3."
We're not sure.
[ Laughter ]
That's right --
as of tonight's taping,
McCarthy has lost 13 times.
[ Audience murmurs ]
They say 13 is unlucky,
but 1 to 12
weren't that great, either,
so, I mean...
[ Laughter ]
And no one knows how
this will turn out for McCarthy.
Right now, there's a
"Congratulations" banner
hanging in his office
with a removable question mark.
[ Laughter ]
You guys see this?
Apparently, last night,
congressman-elect George Santos
was overheard talking
about the speakership fight.
And he actually said,
"You can't make this crap up."
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Then Santos said,
"Well, I can, but you can't."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Santos was like,
"This reminds me of that time
I invented the iPhone."
[ Laughter ]
"It was a sunny day.
I was Jewish."
[ Laughter ]
That was the fourth straight day
of voting,
and you could tell
they were bored,
and they tried to make
the process a little more fun.
Check out how the names
were called out today.
-♪ One more time ♪
[ Laughter ]
-Adams -- Jeffries.
Aderholt -- McCarthy.
-Yeah.
[ Applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Let's change gears.
Some movie news -- today,
"M3GAN,"
the new horror movie about a
killer robot doll, hit theaters.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's great.
That's right --
a horror movie called "M3GAN."
Prince William was like,
"Seen it."
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter continues ]
[ Rim shot ]
-Wow.
-The movie has a running time
of 1 hour and 42 minutes.
It's shocking.
This movie is actually
the length of a movie.
[ Laughter ]
If you duck out --
If you duck out
to watch it during "Avatar,"
you'll only miss one scene.
[ Laughter ]
It's a whale spinning around,
yeah.
Well, the big annual consumer
electronics show
is under way in Las Vegas.
And there are a lot of new
high-tech products on display,
including a smart cutting board
with a built-in screen.
Smart cutting board
Yeah, the inventor was like,
"Okay, fine, it's an iPad."
[ Laughter ]
"But say you put a carrot --
you put a carrot on it..."
That's definitely when I want
to be distracted
with a screen,
when I'm using a knife.
Right? That's...
I saw that Ram unveiled
a new concept truck
with three rows of seats.
It's perfect for the truck guy
who's easing his way
into becoming a minivan guy.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, Sony and Honda
announced
that the name of their new
electric car brand is Afeela.
As in, Afeela they could have
come up with a better name-a.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Applause continues ]
Sony plus Honda equals Afeela?
[ Light laughter ]
That's like if
Brad and Angelina's
couple name was Afeela.
[ Light laughter ]
Well, everyone's talking about
Prince Harry's new book,
as the details
start to come out.
And this is very interesting --
at one point,
Prince Harry writes that
before his brother's wedding,
he actually had frostbite
on his...you know.
How do I put this?
He had -- He had frostbite
on his Little Prince.
[ Laughter ]
-Whoa, no, no, no, no, no.
What you're trying to say is --
all right, how can I put this?
Oh, his Big Ben
became Little Ben.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-No, no, no, no, no.
How do I put this?
Ron Weasley
almost lost his wand.
[ Laughter ]
-No, no, no, no, no, no.
How do I put this?
It was a blizzard in Downton.
[ Laughter ]
-No, no, no, no.
How do I put this?
Charles almost said goodbye
to his Dickens.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-No.
[ Applause continues ]
No.
I think what you're trying
to say is his penis got frozen.
[ Laughter ]
Right?
[ Light laughter ]
Am I wrong?
-Some business news --
I read that Bed Bath & Beyond
is preparing
to file for bankruptcy.
-Ohh.
-It's pretty serious.
The company actually released
a statement...
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what they said.
-That was their release?
-Yeah.
[ Applause continues ]
Now get this --
apparently, Party City
is also about to file
for bankruptcy.
That's surprising.
I mean, if there was one company
you thought
could handle inflation...
[ Laughter ]
They're in the balloon business.
[ Light laughter ]
Somehow, they survived 2020
when throwing parties
were literally illegal,
but they're closing now.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cellphone vibrating ]
How embarrassing.
Sorry, let me check this.
One sec.
Oh, I just got
a new Facebook Memory.
It says that,
two years ago on this day,
I went sledding with my family.
-Aww.
-That was a great time.
-Oh.
[ Phone vibrating ]
Oh.
Hey, here, it says,
two years ago today,
I hosted a small fondue party
with some friends. Hm.
-That sounds really nice.
Higgins, did you get
any Facebook Memories?
What were you doing
two years ago today?
-Today's January 6th?
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter continues ]
-Yeah. Yeah.
-So, two years ago,
what was I doing?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What were you doing
on January 6, 2021?
-Oh, you know what?
Facebook just says,
"Nothing to see. Move on."
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, whatever, man.
You're really not going
to tell us where you were
on January 6th two years ago?
-[ Chuckling ] Oh, here we go.
It says I was sledding.
[ Laughter ]
With you and your family.
-[ Chuckling ] What?
Why would you be sledding
with us?
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
You don't remember?
Me, you, January 6th?
Remember your family?
Sledding?
[ Laughter ]
Now do you remember?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
S-Sure, sure, of course.
Yeah, yeah, I remember that now.
[ Applause ]
-Ah.
Memories.
[ Laughs ]
[ Applause ]
-You came sledding with me
and my...
[ Light laughter ]
Guys, listen to this -- the
company that makes Slim Jims
said that more price increases
are possible.
Yeah. Slim Jims
have gotten so expensive,
they now go
by Slimothy Jimothies.
[ Laughter ]
[ Rimshot ]
-Ohh.
[ Applause ]
Slimothy Jimothies.
[ Laughs ]
And finally,
speaking of tubed meat,
I heard that Oscar Mayer
is looking to hire 12 people
to drive the Wienermobile.
[ Audience cheers ]
It's always annoying
how the Wienermobile drivers
are hired in groups of 12,
while the Bunmobile drivers
are hired in groups of 8.
[ Laughter ]
We have a great show.
From the new horror movie,
"M3GAN,"
Allison Williams is here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Golden Globes host
Jerrod Carmichael
is on the show, tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And we got great music
from Jessie Reyez!
Let's go write
some thank-you notes!